[Music]
with the CH there you go
[Applause]
f
[Music]
[Applause]
so the Jo like I don't ever let you get
started you get do you understand what
I'm saying that's how it stays up with
the fcen it's not that if it moves
faster it's going to move slower but it
you
get it doesn't let you get
started you get it you feel
that and and it occup balance check
right there boom balance check Bo
balance check you got it
let it come
up so switch
CL you're going too early inter on
the you got crushed by the atoshi right
okay come on there so don't don't try to
pick it up there wait for the hand to go
up on that side then this becomes light
okay don't try to pick it up on your
push it's too heavy okay wait for him to
go up last
when he
waight there it is that's do it against
SL
[Music]
try not to use your app use your
your energetic reconciliation just be
patient
[Music]
you're too
low athis
you
got you got to get underneath it
inter don't be afraid do
H
spirit Spirit com there you go don't
worry if you get here
oh go back here line your body
[Applause]
there you go there say there settle
settle
Zin there you go
setle
good
here on this
don't have your hands don't try to show
a change for the the C go
back don't change for the
C you you have to OCC you have to slow
the guy
down by forcing him to
reconcile that his balance is being
pinned got it okay so otherwise you get
there way too fast and you and get
behind maybe maybe you get rid of that
move but on the on the
K you're behind you get okay
so give it your power and your power is
with your hands near your Cent right
here near your Center
okay one two near your Center
okay and so your counter is in
maintaining the ades right do you
understand that so you you can't let
your Joe go climb like you just did CU
it still feel your shoulders I'm still
going to touch okay you have to drop and
rece okay don't let it pin
you you're holding on
[Music]
you're going to hear me in the
face you
me drop your Center on this drop with it
then do your move
drop your Center on your tush no I F you
I cannot feel I should not feel your
feet boom it's not about forward it
might be about
lower okay now you're too
close you're you're there you go
it's going to be the same over here boom
okay and I can't feel your
feet don't let me feel your
feet that's
better
no switch
[Music]
wait
then I can move out from under as you
come up then I can
[Music]
move feel feel okay
[Applause]
can we do the other side
[Music]
do it I'll do it
incorrectly okay it's not that my
Center you're only pinning me if I'm
trying to keep my Center up the problem
is that my Center goes down it's that I
was trying to go up you made it go down
that's a pin if I move my Center down
when you try to make it to it's not a
okay I'm freeing my Center
soft soft
soft and KN that I CT your sword I
remain stuck to your
sword I want you to pay attention to how
you don't feel me at the end you don't
feel my
feet it's no different and if you push
on my shoulder I don't want to do that
you see you felt my feet you push my
shoulder
on you don't feel my feet push feel my
feet push feel don't feel my feet
same thing here boom don't feel my feet
Bo don't feel my
[Applause]
feet in this part
I want you
to follow rotate the whole are okay so
if you pay
attention right now
[Music]
opening I go to
four I go back to four here I want you
to come all the way around now we rotate
three things don't feel the
feet don't feel the feet Bo all the way
around
boom one more
don't feel the feet don't feel the feet
all the way
around let's have you TR remember if I
push on your
shoulder you will move it you're kind of
letting you it's not that you get it out
of the way you let me move
it no let me push you organize your body
as a hole and then I'm allowed to move
there you go organize it just like you
were going to project me you would
organize your whole body now as an
organized unit you let it
move
back okay so if as an organized unit if
you feel me press it'll lower yes it's
not that you get ahead of me you let me
lower it okay here we
go
so let me me lower it
good let me lower it it's got a little
tight there in that
should
boom
yes make me hit void yes void again it's
got you a little
bit so make sure you're at my ribs okay
it's kind of over that way and it's
making you all cadd
wers good there it is right here here
right okay and then lower it you can you
can release the joke yes just don't put
it out here keep it near you okay
Bo
vo I
you're you're like
uncomfortable you feel that try to try
to be where you're
comfortable see how it's out here your
uncomfortable you can't see it in your
stay there go where you are okay get
yourself comfortable where do you want
to
be be comfortable don't forget the form
just you got you know you got a lower
okay so you want your feet closer
together right okay so maybe do
[Music]
that okay stay
there put this under your more and this
you're like Dy to hold on to it let it
slide back okay you have to do what you
have to do to not get pinned
see that hand is
let me see what I
do so what I did is rewind rewind
okay I came here and I just brought
a okay then it's going to pull on my
fingers I drop my center but I'm not
really holding I'm not holding it up
it's just St there that
adhesion that's all I'm doing okay don't
try to lift it cuz that's giving me the
young energy that's pulling you out and
that where
is so if you think about it
this don't if you feel that that's
pulling you drop your weight I feel
that's pulling me I let it go okay and
when you come back I S I Feel the
opening and I grab it
again
Center just don't contest okay
boy boy
better here we
go
good all the way no don't
hop use your glutes
stay
connected
good catching every
time feel be in communion
yes don't
hop feel feel the ground so I'm not
going to I'm not going to hop at you
okay my my body
moves okay got it have power
there
boy good hold
there you
go bo bo
bo
bo bo nope stuck
good come
on it's my job to St King not your job
to
good good
[Music]
see and again the Joe Cuts Cuts you off
that's the logic of the joke don't let
that thing start
swinging so I cut off you see so pay
attention to where you
are with the cut you should never get
there that's too much as soon as you
move I've rotated the cross and attacked
the
hands now I want you to pay attention to
that same thing here same thing as soon
as you get that movement coming I don't
let you get into it otherwise I'm
toast I'm going to give it even if I get
you see how you me
so it's about a stop
it
okay and I don't actually have to move
that that quickly I just have to start
sooner in the same way you void you have
to avoid this don't let me pin you
okay don't let me pin
you don't let me pin you what makes the
pin two things make the
pin one of them is me pushing down
what's the other thing push you're
pushing up do not letting me move you
down okay
you watch How I do this same you come
around my
center it's not enough to do the
rotating cross because of the
at so I going a void Bo void you feel it
it just hit
now my feet boom boom Foy come on Boom
same thing here you go to hips boy okay
you come
in same thing here come back go feel the
weight now boom bo
void
void you should never feel my feet
otherwise he a touch
work
[Music]
vo then my Center drops at the void
Parts cuz you're attacking my
Center okay
here it comes boy Center drops no when
you feel me push let your Center be
pushable now the next move is capturing
your
mind let me push your
Center better I'm going to push it again
drop yes I'm going to push it again drop
nope go back feel it and let it move you
yeah there you
go that's why I was crushing you on that
move drop yes get ready drop yes boom
drop yes you don't need to stay down be
brave on the evening when you piure your
spirit is I Don't Give A F like happens
I'm hitting that guy that's your
spirit
free
Noe let it move you
yes
yes yes that was nice
drop be comfortable when you
Dr
comfortable comfortable
comfortable you're comfortable on the